all right so we're going to talk about
fat burning foods so there are actually
two sets of hormones those are hormones
that trigger fat burning and then there
are hormones that trigger fat storing
and this principle really comes into
play as you age because when you're
young you have a good metabolism you
could pretty much get away with anything
but when as you age you have to consider
the hormones so we want to go and go
away from the calorie counting and focus
more on how foods influence the hormone
effects so I'm going to just cover some
really key points here number one
protein all right if you have the right
amount of protein which is three to four
ounces per meal okay you will trigger
the fat burning process that's why
skipping a meal especially for breakfast
is not a good thing because you're not
triggering any fat burning you're
actually starving your body your [ __ ]
you're creating a starvation reflex and
it'll actually cause more fat storing so
one of the triggering effects of fat
storing hormones is starvation or going
on a diet or being hungry because you're
not eating correctly that's why I think
people will say sometimes like oh yeah
you have to eat like seven meals a day
or you have to keep eating more I'm gay
I'm actually gaining weight because I'm
not eating enough well that may or may
not be true it really has to do with are
you eating enough nutrients in the
calories because but we don't want to go
basically be starving your body alright
so what you want a small amount of
protein anything excess like let's say
10 or even maybe sometimes even 9 10 11
12 13 up to 17 ounces of protein per
meal you go to this restaurant and they
have all this this protein that can
trigger the fat storing hormones and
prevent any chance for weight loss so
just because protein triggers
evaporating doesn't mean you can have a
lot of it now the quality is important
too because if you start doing like the
soy protein isolate powders or which is
in a lot of diet prepackaged foods
that's not high quality it may trigger
the fat storing but it comes with a
package it has a lot of side effects it
might create tumors in the liver
it might make you look old as you lose
weight it's not the best quality to
replace your body tissue so I don't
recommend it in fact I don't recommend a
lot of
protein powders that are with the way or
the soy egg protein pea protein any of
the vegetarian protein powders are
better but I prefer if you have actual
food and then we're going to get into
this thing called fats here fat believe
it or not even though it has more
calories it's neutral when it comes down
to the fat storing or fat burning in
other words having butter for example
won't necessarily just turn into your
hips or stomach weight it's neutral
however when you have certain fats like
greasy deep fried foods that grease can
affect your liver and block the fat
burning process because all the fat
burning hormones work with the liver so
even though it's an indirect effect you
need a healthy liver to burn fat okay so
we don't want to clog up the liver too
much fat but some neutral healthy fats
are totally fine coconut oil I'm not
saying go out of your way to eat them
but don't worry about avoiding them
butter is not a bad thing
safflower oil sunflower oil peanut oil
all that is totally fine but the problem
is like doing the fast food fats that
they would do and the big vats where you
have hydrogenated oils and all this corn
oil and things like that okay so now we
got the carbs all right now this is
interesting because in one of the
premier physiology books in all medical
schools and chiropractic colleges is
called Guyton's
physiology in this book is like the
Bible of physiology and it states that
one of the most powerful triggers of fat
burning hormones is the absence of
carbohydrates so it's not something you
do it's something that you avoid which
is kind of like something you're doing
you're avoiding it but you're not really
eating anything you're just not eating
something and that would be the carbs
and I'm talking about the sugar refined
carbohydrates and refined grains so
let's just talk about that like the
hidden things like like juice or
flavored yogurt that would be hidden or
alcohol those are hidden carbs
and the philosophy of everything in
moderation or portion control doesn't
play into this because all it takes is a
tiny amount of a carbohydrate to block
fat burning and you might not know this
now but you unless you watch my videos
but let's pretend that you had a cookie
okay it's 80 calories you can walk it
off in about 1 mile of walking but the
insulin response and that one cookie if
your metabolism is slow and you're
getting older could inhibit fat burning
hormones by up to 72 hours so all it
takes is tiny amounts and the reason I
mention that is because sometimes will
help people to say well why can't I
don't I don't understand all these fat
people they're so big it's so simple all
you have to eat all you have to do is
portion control and exercise more and
they would lose weight they're just lazy
that's absolutely not true they don't
know that this little piece of
information right here so and when you
take a carbon you add protein it really
spikes the fat storing hormone so like
if you had a hamburger or a sweetened
sour pork at the Chinese restaurant or
or like some type of protein with bread
or sugar that is worse combined than
having them separate so it creates a
more of a effect on the fat storing
hormones that use that comes to play
when you're going out to dinner now MSG
monosodium glutamate that would be
hidden is modified food starch that's a
flavor enhancer that also will spike
insulin by 300% it's in a lot of junk
foods to make the food taste better than
it really is this is a deadly fat
storing a substance because it acts like
sugar almost I mean even worse than
sugar because it creates a spike about
three to three hundred percent more than
sugar so MSG is pretty deadly if you're
trying to lose weight now fruits fruit
doesn't necessarily cause you to gain
weight because of the fiber buffering
effect but if if your metabolism is slow
and really slow the less fruit that you
can eat what I would recommend is trying
to eat a lot of it but hit your goal and
then
in to maintain your weight so fiber does
buffer the insulin response so that
means instead of juicing blend food so
you have all the fiber it's very very
important okay so then we have stress
stress does trigger the fats during
hormones now if your metabolism is slow
and you're burnt out and you're not
sleeping you should not be doing high
intense
you're not going to be able to recover
from it so low recovery no sleep high
exercise you're going to get fat all
right now the best sleep best exercise
to do when you're under stress or you're
not sleeping is low intense exercise
because you will burn more fat than high
intensity depending on your recovery in
your sleep but sleep in general does
help you trigger the fat burning effects
okay so sleep is one of the triggers and
intense exercise is also one of the
triggers if you're sleeping if you are
recovering okay so the exercise seeing
is dependent on your overall health and
your metabolism so what I did is I
actually combined I actually combine all
the hormone triggers for the fat burning
and all the fat storing triggers hormone
triggers for the fat storing effects
right here on one piece of paper I
summarized everything to make it simple
so you can download this form in the
link below and then read it study it
apply it memorize it and then send me
your success stories because this really
does work if you follow it hope you
enjoy this I will see you in the next
video